loudoun county public schools didn't
report multiple alleged sexual assaults
joe biden claims success in his coveted
policy while ignoring the facts and the
white house says that inflation and
supply chain bottlenecks are high class
problems i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder you're
spending way too much on your cell phone
bill you think you have to be with one
of the big providers right because they
have all the best cell phone towers well
here is the thing you can get coverage
the same as one of the big providers but
not pay the same money because all of
those providers are paying for this
massive overhead with pure talk usa
you're not going to be doing that pure
talk doesn't charge you for any of the
garbage that verizon att and t-mobile
will charge you for instead they give
you killer 5g coverage on the same 5g
network as one of the big guys for about
half the cost the average family is
saving over 800 a year so what exactly
is your excuse i made the switch you can
keep your number keep your phone or get
huge discounts on the latest iphones and
androids get a limited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and listen if you still want unlimited
data you can still get it and still save
a fortune go to puretalk.com shop for
the plan that is right for you they have
a 30-day risk-free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you'll save 50 off your very first month
that is puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wire let's go
check them out right now peertalk.com
enter promo code shapiro say 50
off your very first month of coverage
okay so the daily wire has been all over
the situation in loudoun county which
has national implications because
obviously it's going to be very
important for this virginia
gubernatorial race and should terry
mcauliffe lose the gubernatorial race in
virginia basically that's the end of joe
biden's agenda because a bunch of
moderate democrats across the country
are going to look at their seats and
think if terry mcauliffe loses in
relatively blue virginia that means that
the american public are not happy with
the agenda that we are currently pushing
and at that point joe biden's agenda is
basically dead until after the midterms
and probably beyond that the midterms
don't look like they are shaping up well
for him so everyone is focusing in on
loudoun county our reporter luke roziak
over in loudoun county has been doing an
unbelievable job of uncovering the
predations of the school board in
loudoun county and the democratic party
infrastructure in places like virginia
and loudoun county with regard to school
boards by the way the kind of work that
luke is doing that's really expensive
and difficult work that can only happen
because of our daily wire members if
you're already a member thank you for
making that happen because honestly your
membership helped pay for luke but if
you're not a member you really should
join up and help our reporters do the
kind of work that luke is doing it's
making a huge difference out there head
on over to daily wear right now and grab
a membership obviously this has become a
flash point
because the national school board union
came out and basically requested that
the fbi and doj investigate people who
are going to school board meetings and
sounding off on how the school boards
were not doing their job in terms of
educating and protecting their kids well
the the biggest story of the last couple
of months came out via luke a little bit
earlier this week that was the story
surrounding a father who was made the
face of the quote-unquote domestic
terror movement by the national media it
turns out that that father was royally
ticked off at one of these meetings not
because he was domestic terrorist but
because as it turns out there's fairly
good evidence and he alleges that his
daughter was raped in a public school
bathroom by a bisexual boy wearing a
skirt and that the louden county school
board refused to acknowledge that the
sexual assault had even taken place
which might piss off
even the best of us
and so this became a national story well
now it turns out there is even more
according to luke rosiak this morning
loudoun county public schools did not
record multiple known incidents of
alleged sexual assault in schools dating
back several years despite a law that
requires statistics about school safety
incidents to be reported to the public
and which includes provisions holding
school superintendents personally liable
for violations a daily wire review of
public records found after the daily
wire raised the discrepancy with the
virginia department of education the
vdoe spokesman charles pyle said vdoe is
reviewing the disciplined crime and
violence data submissions of loudoun
county public schools and is in
communication with lcps to determine
whether the division's reporting is
accurate and whether the division is in
compliance with state and federal law
the same law could have implications for
loudoun county superintendent or
principal in the wake of a may 28
alleged sexual assault in a bathroom an
incident first reported by the daily
wear on monday on june 22 superintendent
scott ziegler told the public quote to
my knowledge we don't have any record of
assaults occurring in our bathrooms
virginia law requires that reports shall
be made to the division superintendent
and to the principal or his designee on
all incidents involving sexual assault
the daily wire asked lcps questions last
week including quote has stone bridge
ever reported the may alleged sexual
assault in any statistics or made anyone
aware of it
lcps hid behind state law with director
of communications joan solgren replying
quote any information related to student
information is confidential under state
and federal laws regarding student
privacy however
state law actually requires statistics
on assault and other incidents in
schools to be reported to the public in
the form of annually updated statistics
available on a public database called
safe schools information resource
administered by the virginia department
of education in other words the school
board and the school does not have to
report to the public the name of the
people involved the juveniles involved
but they do have to report the numbers
lcps reported to the state that
stonebridge had zero sexual assaults for
the 2020 to 2021 school year which
includes may 28 2021. virginia law says
the super the division superintendent
shall annually report all such incidents
to the doe for the purpose of recording
the frequency of such incidents on forms
that shall be provided to the department
and shall make such information
available to the public
the issue with missing sex assault
statistics in loudon is not limited to
the latest case raising the prospect
that untold numbers of sexual assaults
and other infractions have gone
unreported in october 2018 in a case
that was widely reported by the media at
the time three football players at tesco
herrera tuscarera high were arrested and
charged with sexual assault a source
told local media it's believed a younger
player was held down by teammates who
inserted victims who inserted objects
into the victim in a locker room a
spokesperson for lcps said at the time
the case will be subject to disciplinary
action the annual report for tuscarera
that year reported zero instances of
sexual offenses against students
lcps provided no response at all to the
daily wires questions about the reason
for the zero figures despite having two
days to do so
while the suspect in the may 28th
alleged assault was not arrested until
july 8 following the conclusion of an
investigation police officers were
present at the school that day law
enforcement was notified and a police
report was filed though it was not clear
who filed the report
pyle the state spokesman told
said that the sssr's mandatory reporting
is not contingent on the filing of
charges by law enforcement or subsequent
convictions in other words if this was
reported to the cops that just means
that it has to be reported in the stats
but it wasn't reported in the stats
additionally the safety stats for that
school year were not due to the state
until july 16th and in the case of
tuscarera the school year did not end
until months after the incident and
arrest yet the district still reported
zero and has for every single year since
on wednesday lcps put out a statement we
did not send it to the daily wire it
said quote loudoun county sheriff's
office was contacted within minutes of
receiving the initial report on may 28th
once a matter has been reported to law
enforcement lcps does not begin its
investigation until law enforcement
advises lcps it has completed the
criminal investigation furthermore we
can't discipline any student without
following title ix grievance processes
but an email from stonebridge principal
tim flynn which was sent to the entire
community at 448 the day of the alleged
rape told students and parents that
quote there was an incident in the main
office area today that required the
loudoun county sheriff's office to
dispatch deputies to stone bridge
this corresponds to the story offered by
scott smith the victim's father who said
the police arrived because the school
called them on him for making a scene
about his impression it was not treating
the incident seriously
so this is a disaster area for loudoun
county if it turns out that the loudoun
county schools have not been reporting
these stats on sexual assault to the
public just another indicator that when
you have institutions that are very
powerful they have every incentive to
cover up
all of the bad things happening within
those institutions this is true across
institutions
people develop institutional loyalty
when they work for those institutions
and they don't want to report the bad
stuff happening inside the institutions
and that's how you end up with children
being put in danger
now for the left they don't care
apparently if those children are put in
danger by the public schools and they're
a wide variety of cases in which
teachers have
have made prey out of their students in
public schools across the country those
statistics are in fact somewhat
available
it's a national story when it's the
catholic church it's not a national
story when it turns out that it's the
public school system obviously even
though there are many many more members
of the public school system in the
united states than there are members of
the catholic church who are subject to
predation
okay there's certainly an ideological
component here
and meanwhile the family of that girl
who's allegedly raped in her school
bathroom is now pursuing civil action
against the loudoun county public
schools under title ix
so there will in fact be a lawsuit
the parents of the young girls stayed
quote subsequent to the sexual assault
on our daughter loudoun county public
schools formalized the policy regarding
restroom use that was easily exploitable
by a potential sexual assailant because
of poor planning and misguided policies
loudoun schools failed to institute even
minimal safeguards to protect students
from sexual assault
the lawyer for the family says the
conduct of loudoun county schools and
the loudoun school board directly
resulted in the brutal rape of smith's
daughter at stonebridge high it only
takes an instant to see how loud and
county schools have adversely affected
this family and have harmed their
daughter
so
all of this has resulted in some pretty
bad
news for terry mcauliffe who's running
for governor of virginia and who is
completely in hawk to the teachers
unions in the state of virginia he was
asked yesterday about whether parents
should be in charge of education and
this of course remains a major issue
right across the country parents would
like to be in charge of their children's
education public schools are delegated
your kids to educate them in the ways
that you see fit they're not delegated
to the power to educate them solely as
they see fit
because frankly they are not qualified
to do so nor empowered to do so that is
not the purpose of local public schools
and the federalization of the process
has made this worse it's created a
massive disconnect between the
bureaucrats who are supposed to educate
your children and you
this is why increasingly parents are
taking their kids out of the public
schools putting them in private schools
homeschooling them trying to find
charter schools doing anything they can
to renew to remove the monopoly on
indoctrination now provided by liberal
teachers unions
and the and the state-run
schooling system so terry mcauliffe was
asked about all of this because he had
said in open debate with glenn youngkin
in virginia that parents essentially
have no interest in the education of
their kids it's really the state's job
to educate the kids here is terry
mcauliffe erupting when asked about it
who do you think should be in control of
education if not virginia parents
vaccinated yeah that's the question i
want to know who do you think should be
in control of education if not
virginia's parents governor was in him
you're dangerous here closed last year
i'll build education that's right
that's why fox news has me leading uncle
destroy virginia's education system what
a joke terry mcauliffe is what a joke so
he's asked whether parents should be in
control of education and he starts
lecturing the guy about a mask they're
standing outside he's literally walking
to his car if you can't see the clip
he's literally walking to his car and
just yelling at this reporter
saying that he should be wearing a mask
and then he says i'll take care of
education glenn young can we'll destroy
it yeah sure
sure
so terry cough is in real trouble in
this race hey this should not be a close
race
the the virginia
political map has been turning blue for
quite a while right now the results in
virginia in the 2020 election were
heavily in favor of course of hillary uh
in favor of joe biden joe biden won the
state by 10 points in 2020. right now
young kin is who's a relative no name is
running neck and neck with terry
mcauliffe a former virginia governor
it's the fact that this is even close is
a referendum on how bad people think
democratic governance is even in
democratic states
this has relegated terry mcauliffe to
basically trying to treat
glenn youngkin as though he is donald
trump and also greg abbott which of
course is not true here is terry
mcauliffe trying to say that glen yonkin
is going to ban abortion in the state of
virginia which of course is not going to
happen i mean unfortunately from my
point of view but that's not what's
going to happen in the state of virginia
i protected women's rights he is going
to ban abortions we got him on tape
saying that wants to ban abortions in
virginia and i'll tell you andrew that's
a real issue for everyone today for 50
years we thought the supreme court would
protect everybody with roe v wade trump
supreme court if glenn juncken is
elected governor of virginia abortions
will cease and i gotta tell you it's
dangerous for women dangerous for
doctors and you can't bring businesses
on recruited amazon to virginia they're
not coming to a state that discriminates
he's having a really tough time
mcauliffe putting a target on yonkin's
back because mcauliffe is the issue here
not trump and not junkin and when it
comes to education americans have very
simple questions to ask like why are you
guys doing an unbelievably crappy job
brand new report out says the nation's
13 year olds are less proficient in math
and reading than they were almost a
decade ago that is not because of the
coveted pandemic that was data collected
before the start of the pandemic and
released on thursday according to the
national assessment of education
progress this political reporting this
is the first time these scores have
dropped in either subject in the 50 50
year history of the test
the students who struggle the most with
the exam have fallen further behind a
worrisome result that suggests learning
loss exacerbated by the pandemic could
be catastrophic
math scores fell furthest among students
whose performance ranked in the 10th and
25th percentiles meaning test takers
with the lowest math scores in 2020 did
worse than students who struggled the
most when the test was last administered
in 2012. the data also shows the
achievement gap between white and black
test takers widened
nationally math scores for 13 year olds
fell on average by five points reading
scores declined on average three points
none of these results are impressive
said the commissioner of the national
center for education statistics they're
all concerning the math results were
particularly daunting
so basically your schools are failing to
educate kids particularly the kids who
are at the lowest end of the spectrum
and meanwhile they're indoctrinating
them in all the worst values not
protecting them and you wonder why we
have a schools crisis right now you
wonder why so many parents are
interested in pulling their kids out of
school and you wonder why so many people
are looking at scans at democratic
administrations who seem solely
concerned with pleasing teachers unions
you you wonder why so many americans are
upset with maybe the fbi and the doj
doing the bidding of the very people who
are failing to educate their kids and
then claiming complete plenary authority
over those children
none of this is good news for democrats
obviously
meanwhile as the cascade of bad
headlines is just swamping
the the democrats right now
the
the biden administration is struggling
for a narrative the narrative that they
are now coming up with is that they have
defeated covid yes yes it was them they
did it it was the mandatory vaccine
mandate sure it was it was that
so yesterday joe biden wandered out to a
microphone and he spoke for a grand
total of seven minutes and then he
turned around and then he left
okay so
i mean that's all he can be expected to
do like he shows up every day he talks
for like 37 seconds and then he sort of
collapses out of the room and it's
dragged back to his casket where they
where they
perform some sort of
resuscitory action upon him and then uh
he breathes lightly until the next day
when they pull him out of the casket
again and wheel him out so president
biden yesterday he came out and he said
our plan is working
oh interesting okay explain mr president
i want to provide a brief update on my
plan
and announced in early september to
accelerate the path out of this pandemic
it's working we're making progress
nationally
daily cases are down 47 percent
hospitalizations are down 38 over the
past six weeks
over the past two weeks
most of the country has improved as well
case rates are declining in 39 states
and hospital rates are declining in 38
states okay let me point out how stupid
this is okay the reason that this is
unbelievably stupid
is because there are several reasons
reason number one the states that have
seen the larger scale declines are
states that have completely ignored joe
biden
florida never had vaccine mandates in
fact rhonda has been fighting vaccine
mandates pretty much every step of the
way and has vaccination rates that are
about the same as the vaccination rates
in california for example they're not
wildly different
okay joe biden is suggesting that it is
him yelling about vaccines that has
caused the pandemic to wayne that old
man shouting at clouds made the pandemic
wane nope
all that happened is that the pandemic
hits populations who spend lots of times
indoors
and then it wanes because it passes
through the population this is what
pandemics do
but this is joe biden's tried and true
method right there's a parade already
moving he jumps out in front of it and
claims credit for the parade
he did this with the vaccine rollout
itself he didn't have one iota to do
with the development of the vaccine his
vaccine rollout plan was the same as
trump's and then he jumped in front of
the parade and he was like well here i
am
and look at how i did it it was me
success
and now he's doing the exact same thing
so the pandemic wanes mostly in red
states where it had spiked and he's like
look what i did and joe look at me i'm
great at that
[Music]
amazing i'm amazing how he jumps in
this is constantly the policy of bad
bureaucrats
is that the problem already starts to
solve itself and then they jump in front
of it and they go oh it was me i did it
okay so according to joe biden joe biden
solved the pandemic by yelling at clouds
in reality his plan has not worked it is
also worthy of noting at this point that
all the vaccine mandates that he
supposedly used in order to get the
vaccine rates up the only one that has
actually been implemented at this point
is the federal contractor mandate there
is still no rule from it's been like
almost two months now there is still no
rule from osha that actually mandates
that employers over 100 employees
have to have to backs their people
so to credit his vaccine mandates with
the uptick in vaccination rates is a
stretch in and of itself
it is quite possible that one of the
reasons you saw an uptick in vaccination
rates is specifically because people
looked at the delta variant they said
okay i now have a choice i can either
get delta or not get delta i prefer not
to get delta i prefer to get the vaccine
and then if i get a breakthrough case
it'll be mild
but again joe biden's going to claim
credit for everything now what's amazing
about joe biden and our current
authoritarians
is that they truly believe that you are
bad you are divisive because you refuse
their their authoritarian mandates this
is an incredible statement from joe
biden what we're about to play so joe
biden is talking about divisiveness
now joe biden came into office on the
pledge that he was going to unify he
instead has proposed an agenda that
looks very much like bernie sanders
economic agenda and he's proposed a
covet agenda that is full top down
authoritarian in many ways
so he has completely run beyond his own
political mandate so joe biden came into
office with a political mandate it was
to be dead right not alive not trump and
moderate
two of those three he has fulfilled he
is dead he is not trump but he is
certainly not moderate
and yet according to joe biden it is it
is you
you
who are dividing the country you you
won't listen to him and you won't do
what he wants you're dividing the
country now i noted this literally the
day of his inauguration in his speech he
kept talking about unity and i said well
there are two types of unity there's
unity in the sense that we'll leave you
alone and then we'll try to find some
higher purpose we can all pursue
together
but it's mostly gonna be us leaving you
alone right unity requires us to go
weapons down or unity could be you do
exactly what i want at point of gun and
now we're unified aren't we it's pretty
obvious which way joe biden has moved so
yesterday here he was saying that
vaccine mandates should not divide us i
have an idea don't do them then
let's be clear
vaccination requirements should not be
another issue that divides us
that's why
we continue to battle the misinformation
that's out there
and companies and communities are
setting up their
stepping up as well
to
combat these
the misinformation
southwest airlines
at the head of the pilot the head of the
pilots union and the ceo dismissed
critics who claim vaccination mandates
contributed to flight disruptions well
who are you going to believe joe biden
about the vaccine mandates contributing
to flight disruptions or your own lying
eyes which demonstrate that there was
really no other problem in the united
states and southwest was the only
airline that had been significantly
affected who are you going to believe
about that or the southwest employees
who we've been talking to here at daily
wire who are explaining exactly why
people are sticking out
okay so
there is such an authoritarian streak in
this guy he mandates that you do a thing
if you don't do the thing you're being
divisive
if you refuse to acquiesce to his
demands you are the divisive one you're
a very divisive person for not doing
exactly what joe biden is telling you to
do that's an unbelievably authoritarian
and tyrannical statement
and then joe biden just scampers away
when i say scampers i mean he walks very
slowly away because he's not capable of
scampering anymore those legs ain't
gonna do it so here is joe biden just
walking away after seven minutes in the
glare of the public spotlight
thank you very much
[Applause]
and then joe biden kind of he kind of
fades away
joe biden
old presidents don't die they just walk
away
there's there's that president of the
united states just sort of he came out
for a moment and then he went back down
into his hole which means i believe
six more weeks of winter
okay so here's the thing it is pretty
obvious that whatever surge we had and
waning we had had nothing to do with joe
biden
according to the new york times after a
brutal summer surge driven by the highly
contagious delta variant the coronavirus
is again in retreat the united states is
recording roughly 90 000 new infections
a day down more than 40 since august
hospitalizations and deaths are falling
too
the crisis is not over everywhere the
situation in alaska is particularly dire
but nationally the trend is clear and
hopes are rising that the worst is
finally behind us again over the past
two years the pandemic has crashed over
the country in waves inundating
hospitals and then receding only to
return after americans let their guard
down i love how the new york times puts
that so it's that americans let their
guard down that causes the pandemic to
spike except that it's spiking in blue
areas too it is all about are you in
proximity to other people when it's cold
outside people go inside and then they
get infected when it's really hot
get infected
okay that's all
and this baseline notion that if you get
infected it's because you have been
sinful in some way is ridiculous a lot
of the people who are getting infected
are people who got vast they're just
getting
breakthroughs
the new york times says it's difficult
to tease apart the reasons the virus
ebbs and flows in this way and harder
still to predict the future
uh no it's actually not all that
difficult to explain i just did it in
two sentences as winter looms there are
real reasons for optimism nearly 70
percent of adults are fully vaccinated
many children under 12 are likely to be
eligible for their shots in a matter of
weeks federal regulators could soon
authorize the first anti-viral pill for
covid at 19. by the way joe biden said
yesterday that parents are going to
sleep more solidly at night knowing that
their children won't be in danger
because of the vaccine
those of us who've been watching the
stats have been sleeping solidly at
night about our kids for long i wasn't
sleeping solidly about my parents my
parents are 65. i've been sleeping very
solidly about my seven five and
one-year-old because kids aren't dying
of this in anything remotely like
significant numbers
if that is not morally significant
numbers every every kid who dies is a
morally significant life but if you're
talking about statistical significance
the grand total number of kids who have
died in the united states from covet 19
without serious pre-existing conditions
according to dr martin mccary of johns
hopkins university is currently between
10 and 20.
now 10 and 20 000 10 and 20. hey that is
not the kind of thing that keeps me
awake at night
i am not kept awake at night by the fact
that 10 to that my child
is in significant danger if 10 to 20
kids across a country of 330
million people have died of coved
without pre-existing conditions
okay but again you must be you must be
cudgelled
into into
the belief that these people have solved
the problem as opposed to you know the
virus just doing what the virus does
and my favorite thing about all this is
that we're supposed to believe all these
folks right you heard joe biden a moment
ago talking about how you know none of
this should be divisive we should just
be listening to our authorities we
should be listening to our institutions
except that our institutions have
routinely lied to us
aside from dr anthony fauci who shifts
his opinion every 5.3 seconds depending
on whatever joe biden wants from him
that day our media are just liars
so honestly one of the funniest things
that i've seen in the in the past couple
of months joe rogan did a segment with
sanchez gupta of cnn and honestly
floured his widow because rogan just
destroyed him it really is it really was
quite incredible he had gupta on and he
asked him so uh sanjay i have a question
i took ivermectin
it is not a horsey warmer it is a
medication your entire network claimed
that it was a horse dewormer
why don't you tell the members of your
network it is not a horsey warmer and
tell them to stop lying to people
so then sanjay gupta went back on tv on
cnn and he had his chance
and he said nothing because he's getting
paid by cnn so here's don lemon trying
to explain it's fine to call ivermectin
a horsey warmer even though that is not
the form of ivermectin that joe rogan
was taking
i know it's in large part a
tongue-in-cheek interview you know
because it's joe rogan and there's a lot
of you're jockeying back and forth
but he he did say something about
ivermectin that i think wasn't actually
correct about cnn and lying okay
ivermectin
is a drug that is commonly used as a
horse dewormer so it is not a lie to say
that the drug is used as a horse
dewormer
i i think that's important and it is not
approved for covid
correct that's right
that's that's not right okay it's not
approved for covid by the by the fda but
the notion that ivermectin which comes
in a variety of forms that was that joe
rogan was like taking a tube of horse
paste and then ingesting it is insane
and sanjay gupta admitted that to joe
rogan and then he went on cnn and then
he nodded along while don lemon
continues to lie about it it's unreal
but don't worry you should trust these
these are not the divisive people they
are not you are divisive you're divisive
for not listening to them meanwhile
these experts the one who are gonna fix
everything
this is this is the story of the day it
is unreal to me
so um these experts the people who are
gonna fix all your problems right
they're gonna hit that magic button all
the problems are gonna be fixed it's
going to be incredible
um pete booty judge is the secretary of
transportation we are currently having
in the united states the worst shipping
crisis in my lifetime and i'm nearly 40
years old this is the worst shipping
crisis we've had in the united states in
my lifetime the secretary of
transportation you might think might
have some things to to do right i mean
we've had this shipping bottleneck it's
been ongoing in the united states since
the summer you might think that the
secretary of transportation would be
necessary
p buddha judge
was on paternity leave
since august
hey politico is now reporting that pete
booty judge
was just gone
and no one noticed
that's how important pete bootjudge is i
mean while he was waxing philosophic
about the beauty of the smells of the
airport
people who were actually spending the
last two months this brilliant young
mind from south bend indiana who
couldn't fill a damn pothole over there
pete boudijaj has been home with his
husband jason and their two children
and um
yeah
that's that's great
so
that's um
that's exciting stuff
he's just been gone for two months and
no one noticed
which means that he is a complete
useless person
i mean i have a question for you if you
just went m.i.a for two months
right you just went m.i.a didn't bother
to replace you nobody bothered to tell
anybody you just went m.i.a how long do
you think you would keep your job this
means that your job is more vital than
people who judges
by the way according to internal
democratic polling he's second only to
kamala harris in terms of who the
democrats want to see run for president
again
a man so useless that he took two months
off in the middle of a shipping crisis
as the head of the department of
transportation
to be home with two babies
that that's that's
again nothing against paternity leave
although i will say i think two months
is a very long time for paternity leave
especially when there's no physical
recovery involved but
with that said
if you're gonna take paternity leave and
you're in a real important job shouldn't
like some and you're a public servant
shouldn't like somebody know about it
according to politico
they didn't previously announce it but
buddha judge's office told west wing
playbook the secretary has actually been
on paid leave since mid-august to spend
time with his husband jason and their
two newborn babies
a spokesperson for the department of
transportation said quote for the first
four weeks he was mostly offline except
for major agency decisions and manager
and matters that could not be delegated
he's been ramping up activities since
then
as he does that booty judge will
continue to take some time over the
coming weeks to support his husband and
take care of his new children the
spokesperson added
amazing amazing these are the people we
need in charge they're going to fix
everything
they're so good at that they just went
completely awol for two months and no
one even noticed they weren't this is
office space now
it's ron livingston from office space
right i'm not gonna quit i'm just not
gonna work anymore i think i'm done
working what is it that you say you do
hear exactly
hey but here's the thing democrats are
just gonna continue to pretend that
nothing bad is happening
it's truly incredible so former treasury
secretary lauren summers larry summers
who's the treasury secretary under bill
clinton
he points out that we are now in a very
serious economic position we have
massive inflation it is now permanent
or semi-permanent we have a serious
shipping bottleneck that is not going to
be solved anytime soon we have millions
of workers who are quitting the
workforce
4.3 million workers left the workforce
last month
and here is larry summers pointing out
this is all kind of serious is it not
in the 60s we saw before there were any
adverse supply shots we saw inflation
move from having a one handle in 1966 to
having a six handle by
and we've got much larger budget
deficits today than we did then
we've got much more in the way of supply
bottlenecks emerging much sooner
than uh we did then
so i think we're looking at a very
serious uh kind of uh
situation meanwhile the ceo of morgan
stanley says you remember all those
times they kept telling you over and
over that uh inflation was transitory it
was going to go away soon joe biden's
been saying that for months james gorman
the ceo and chairman of morgan stanley
is like yeah not so much
i'm not a buyer of this story that it's
all transitory the inflation story it's
not transitory i mean wage inflation is
real and the supply chain interruptions
and you were talking about some of the
natural gas and other things have have
clearly been real some of that is
temporary but not all of it so i think
we're in a period where inflation is
going to tick up
yep okay but but here's the thing
according to this administration
this isn't a big deal these are high
class problems
so jason furman
who is some sort of a reporter slash
commentator he said most of the economic
problems we're facing inflation supply
chains etc are high-class problems we
wouldn't have had them if the
unemployment rate was still 10
we would instead have had a much worse
problem
and ron clayne who is the white house
chief of staff and who spends all day on
twitter remember that time that trump
was bad because he was on twitter all
day so ron klain who's on twitter like
all day long like all day he tweets this
meaning he agrees with this so he agrees
that inflation and supply chain problems
are quote unquote high class problems
right these are good problems it's a
good problem that you're paying like a
crapload of money at the store for basic
goods it's a great problem that you
can't get christmas presents for your
kids and these are these are great
problems to have aren't they because the
alternative apparently according to this
administration the only two alternatives
are one ten percent unemployment and two
massive inflation and supply chain
bottlenecks
or alternatively your policy created the
problems
your policy is creating these problems
so chen saki was asked about this and
honestly she is just
she's the night nurse for this
administration they crap the bed she
tries to clean it up i kind of feel bad
for her except she volunteered into the
job here's jen saki
so jason furman of course is more than
capable of speaking or tweeting for
himself obviously and providing any
additional context but
what the point is here is that uh is
that we are at this point because we've
made progress in the economy and what
would be worse in our view is if the
unemployment rate was at 10 people were
out of work hundreds of thousands of
people were still dying of kovid uh and
people weren't able to lose their homes
so that's the full context
oh that's yeah it's oh good full context
i'm i'm so glad i'm so glad that she's
now provided the full context it turns
out that democrats can always claim that
the alternative is complete destruction
of all that is good as opposed to you
know the mostly destruction of all that
is good that is happening right now in a
second i want to get to the underlying
rationale for why so many democrats seem
pretty sanguine about all this because
for most people who are out there it
makes a difference if they're paying
higher bills for most people who are out
there it makes a difference if they are
losing in terms of real wages
for most people out there it matters if
they can get christmas presents for
their kids like this stuff tends to
matter to people so why are democrats so
sanguine about it there's something
ideological to we'll get to it in just
one second first let us talk about the
simple fact that you need a good night's
sleep you've heard me talk about my
helix sleep mattress which i rely upon
each and every evening but helix doesn't
just do
mattresses anymore they're now doing
something different they've started
making sofas they just launched a new
company it's called all form they're
making premium customizable sofas and
shares shipped directly to your door so
what makes an all form sofa really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize a sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it is spill stain scratch
resistant that stuff is very handy when
you have kids the sofa color the color
of the leg sofa size and shape make sure
it is perfect for you and your home
they're great by the way they're
delivered directly to the door they're
they're very easy to put together i'm in
all forms so if i picked out the
three-seat sofa with chase and the sand
color with espresso legs it is super
duper comfortable it is awesome
and if getting a sofa without trying it
in store sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund they also have a forever
warranty literally for all time all form
is offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at allform.com to find your
perfect sofa check out allform.com
we're going to get to more in a moment
including the real question as to why
democrats seem so sanguine about all of
this first it is that glorious time of
the week when i give a shout out to a
daily ware member today it's david
burnett on instagram who knows what it
takes to excel during the long hospital
work hours in this picture david and his
wife are in an operating room dressed in
their scrubs and proudly displaying the
world's most elite tumbler the caption
reads quote whether she's delivering
babies or he's an icu nurse that's now
practicing healthcare law we both fuel
our day and satisfy our thirst with the
tears of our ideological opponents in
the leftist year's tumblr the greatest
of all beverage vessels look out world
you can't flee the truth forever
true true debt as the children say
thanks for the pick and for being a
daily wire member also we had a lot of
exciting announcements to make at our
showing of backstage at the ryman this
past tuesday because the daily wire is
fulfilling our promise of bringing you
even more non-woke content you literally
will not find anywhere else a very
special guest helped us deliver one of
those announcements our good friend adam
carolla comedian and host of the adam
corolla show corolla is joining the
daily wire oh yes for a comedy series
that'll deliver the last you need with
the truth you deserve we cannot wait to
share the final product with you i'm
super pumped about this i mean comedy is
dying corolla's keeping it alive and we
are going to be dropping the first few
episodes of our new show with adam
corolla in november with more to come
early next year there is no better time
to join us than right now head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe enter code
2022 for 25 off your membership that is
dailywire.com subscribe
code2022 for 25 off a new dailywear
membership and stay tuned for more
updates and new content
plus
it has been an exciting week for the
daily wire this weekend sunday special
is only making it better i'm joined by
none other than barry weiss the
iconoclastic writer journalist and now
the voice of her own excellent podcast
called honestly with barry weiss we sat
down to make sense of all that is going
on today it's truly worth the listen
really important conversation here's a
sneak peek
there's one word that sums up how we've
gotten to this insane pass and it's
cowardice the number one ingredient that
if it were present would change the
outcome of almost all of these stories
all of the smearing of good people for
maybe at worst making a mistake
is is courage
it's a story of cowardice and courage
the moment that we're in
[Music]
fairy is a fascinating character her
evolution is really really interesting
and she is a creative thinker who's
really got some stones go check it out
this sunday at dailywire.com or on my
youtube channel ben shapiro dailywire
members get access to special bonus
content from sunday's special episode so
don't miss out join daily wire today
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the big question here is why
democrats seem so sanguine about the
current financial situation
and maybe the reason is they're happy to
transform work there's an article in the
wall street journal today talking about
scarcity of labor
it says 4.3 million workers are missing
where did they go
scarce labor is becoming a fixture of
the us economy reshaping the workforce
prodding firms to adapt by raising wages
reinventing services and investing in
automation more than a year and a half
into the pandemic the us is still
missing around 4.3 million workers
that's how much bigger the labor force
would be if the participation rate the
share of the population 16 or older
either working or looking for work
returned to its february 2020 level of
63.3 percent in september it was just
61.6 percent the absence comes as u.s
employers are struggling to fill more
than 10 million job openings and meet
soaring consumer demand
in another sign of how tight the labor
market is jobless claims fell to 293 000
last week the first time since the
pandemic began that they fell below 300
000 according to the labor department
workers are quitting at or near the
highest rates on record in sectors such
as manufacturing retail trade
transportation utilities as well as
professional and business services
participation has fallen broadly across
demographic groups and career fields but
has dropped particularly fast among
women workers without a college degree
and those in low-paying service
industries like hotels restaurants and
child care
many economists expected that people
would come back to work but some
economists are concerned that worsening
worker shortages reflect longer-term
shifts such as the pandemic-driven
acceleration of retirements that will
not reverse
many expect the labor shortage to last
at least several more years some say
it's permanent of the 52 economists
surveyed by the wall street journal 22
predicted participation would never
return to its pre-pandemic levels
so where exactly are all of these people
going
well many of them
are either going back home if you're
married if you're married couple maybe
mom is going back home and dad is
picking up some extra hours which is
fine
or maybe people are just you know
staying out of jobs because they think
the government's going to pay for them
goldman sachs said in a note this month
that enhanced unemployment benefits have
likely contributed to the shortage
when the pandemic began jessie stromwick
was a senior engineering manager at a
small software from in portland oregon
supervising a couple dozen employees
in the pandemic there were a lot of
challenges in our business i was called
upon to deal with said stromlik just
tapping that button all the time is
really tiring the birth of his son last
november added to his doubts about
whether the job's rewards were worth the
sacrifices he initially looked for other
opportunities when a friend suggested he
take time off entirely strawmak was
intrigued
is that even a thing you can do in
capitalism he recalls thinking his wife
a nurse midwife supported the move the
federal government has allowed borrowers
like his wife to suspend student loan
payments through january 2022. the
couple also refined their mortgage at a
lower interest rate okay so this is all
government policy now right the
government has prevented people from
having to pay back their student loans
and they're artificially lowering the
mortgage rates those adjustments have
saved around two thousand dollars a
month
strongwook's plan three months off has
now stretched to five months and might
last until the end of the year
two years ago i was thinking i want to
get as high as i can on the corporate
ladder he said it just
interests me less now if it comes with
the sacrifice to my mental health and my
connection with my family
employers are overhauling their business
models to adjust for the labor shortages
okay bottom line is this people look at
the way the democrats are running things
and they believe
in their heart of hearts apparently that
there will never be a cost to this they
can stay out of the workforce and people
will just take care of them there will
be programs that are designed to
artificially either boost wages for one
of the people
or that will pay them just to stay home
paul krugman for one is celebrating this
as the keynesian he is
he says
it's not surprising many workers are
either quitting or reluctant to return
to their old jobs
the harder question is why now many
americans hated their jobs two years ago
but they didn't act on those feelings as
much as they are now what changed
well it's only speculation but it seems
quite possible the pandemic by upending
many americans lives also caused some of
them to reconsider their life choices
not everyone can afford to quit a hated
job but a significant number of workers
seem ready to accept the risk of trying
something different except that if you
look statistically the people who are
not going back to work are people who
are at the lower end of the economic
spectrum not people who are middle class
and upper end and it is people who are
more likely to end up on the dole
but according to krugman this is a good
thing he says while this new choosing us
by workers who feel empowered is making
consumers and business owners lives more
difficult let's be clear overall it's a
good thing american workers are
insisting on a better deal it's in the
nation's interest they get it a good
thing for whom
prices have been skyrocketing because of
lack of labor
the people who are working are getting
raises but those races are not
commensurate with the inflation rates
meanwhile we have to blow out the debt
to keep up with the
the price adjusted increases for
mandatory programs like social security
and the administration wants to blow out
more money in order to pay for all those
people who don't want to work remember
when aoc at one point said and we need
to create a system where we pay for
everybody who is either unable or
unwilling to work she wasn't kidding and
many democrats feel this way
there's a fascinating article in the
nation which of course is a far-left
source
by a guy named aaron benev benanav
called making a living the history of
what we call work and he really kind of
spills the beans on what it is that the
left would like here what the left would
like is to change your consuming habits
so that you are satisfied with less
and so we can redistribute everything in
the way that the left would like
what they want is economic stagnation
and redistribution that is the goal of
the left at this point they want to
they see work as an inherent bad and
there's a belief in the minds of the
left about human nature and that belief
is that if you are freed from the
predations of work all work being a form
of exploitation if you are freed from
the predations of work you will become a
poet and an artist you remember nancy
pelosi actually said this
nancy pelosi at one point said that she
wanted to free people from job lock
through obamacare right you wouldn't be
locked to your job because you need
health care and then maybe you'd be able
to wander around and create art and
poetry because that's exactly what
people typically on welfare do i mean if
you've ever looked at the crowd of
people creating great art great poetry
in this country it is predominantly
coming from people who are requiring
government benefits those are the people
who are just the heart and soul
of of creativity and innovation in the
united states
so according to this author in the
nation he's writing about a book called
work a deep history from the stone age
to the age of robots
about a by a anthropologist named james
susman
okay and the basic idea of this book is
that for the vast majority of human
history human beings have lived as
hunter-gatherers on diets consisting of
fruits vegetables nuts insects fish and
game
the idea behind this book is that while
the myth goes that people live in
scarcity when they're hunter-gatherers
that they're living in relative
privation on the edge of starvation or
death that's not actually true
according to the book fire pre-digest
food when you roast the flesh of a
woolly mammoth the process yields
significantly more calories than if the
food was left to uncook mastering fire
thus made for a radical increase in
humanity's free time because early
humans were able to get more out of the
food that they had and therefore they
had a lot of free time
according to that author free time
subsequently shaped our species cultural
evolution leisure afforded long periods
of hanging around with others which led
to the development of language
storytelling in the arts human beings
also can gain the capacity to care for
those who are too old to feed for
themselves a trait we share with few
other species
so again the idea is that we should be
more like the hunter-gatherers
right we should we should abandon the
way that we see production entirely and
instead we should aim for a system in
which we basically do the subsistence
minimum and we can spend the rest of our
time hanging out and partying and having
ourselves a good time
and this is the basic idea here now the
question is why that hasn't happened
right so one of the questions is why if
that's true if human beings just want to
basically cover their basic needs and
then move on with their lives and hang
out and party why aren't more humans
doing this
the answer for the left is that you have
all been corrupted by the capitalist
system which makes you want things
and because you want things
this leads you to the chaining of
yourself to the machine you chain
yourself to the work
according to this author for the nation
john kenneth galbraith provided one
plausible answer in the affluent society
in it he suggested that john maynard
keynes had underestimated the degree to
which we can manipulate it into seeing
our relative wants his absolute needs
meaning stuff that's marginal to us we
can see them as absolute needs now
most economists on the right will say
there's no such thing really as a
prioritization of need that is absolute
beyond like full-on basic necessities
like you have to have enough food and
water to live aside from that we all
prioritize our needs differently and we
get to make those choices subjectively
but what the left would like to do is
force you to prioritize your needs in
the way that the left wants you to
prioritize your needs and then
redistribute all income to create a new
a new kind of human being a new kind of
altruistic wondrous human being who's
more like the hunter-gatherers now never
mind that hunter-gatherer societies tend
to have life expectancies that are
really really low
like in the middle of this article the
author cites the kung bushmen okay the
kung bushmen have an average life
expectancy of somewhere between 40 and
50 years old
also it turns out that prosperity comes
with low infant mortality rates and
being able to keep your elderly alive
for longer but all of this doesn't
matter because obviously work is the bad
at the end of this article in the nation
the author comes to the conclusion
he says we should set the course not to
mars vacationing with elon musk and jeff
bezos
but rather to oppose to scarcity planet
earth on which their wealth has been
confiscated and put to better ends the
ends of the left of course getting there
will require that we overcome the
endemic insecurity that continues to
plague nine tenths of humanity while
also reducing and transforming the work
we do
achieving those ends will in turn
require that we transform the investment
function as keen suggested but in ways
that make investment not only public but
democratically controlled freed from the
constraints of scarcity economics will
then serve the trickster god entropy
what he's talking about there is the
idea that human beings like to work and
you're going to have extra energy so you
just go make stuff so instead of you
going and working and innovating and
making life better for other people
instead
we will serve the trickster god entropy
in new ways expanding expending excess
energy not only in the hunt for
efficiency gains or in making whatever
hand acts as our engineers room up next
but also in the service of a variety of
other ends such as justice and
sustainability science and culture and
throwing parties too a new better
humanity will be ushered in through the
collective is the idea here
i don't think this article in the nation
is far off the thinking of many people
in the democratic party work is
inherently bad leisure is inherently
good
anything that causes you to work whether
it is your like this is the direct
opposite of sort of the randian approach
to work the iranian approach to work is
that work is an outgrowth of your
creative function
and when you do creative things
what you're actually doing is fulfilling
yourself which is true for a huge number
of people who work
work gives people purpose
work is not a bad thing but the left
sees work is a bad thing they believe
that if you had more leisure time what
you would really be spending that doing
is stuff that doesn't you wouldn't take
drugs you wouldn't get addicted to
alcohol
unemployment would come with just vast
benefits we would sit around campfires
we'd tell each other stories we would
think about justice and sustainability
we'd hug the trees and all the rest
so that is why so many people seem
pretty sanguine about the high rates of
people dropping out of the economy it's
actually creating the utopia they seek
which is some people work a lot of hours
and really hard to produce for everybody
else and then we redistribute all the
gains
right now some people see that as a
violation of liberty principles some
people see that as i do as a violation
of basic human nature which is that
people need to work it is good for
people to work work is not a bad thing
and the notion that people expend extra
leisure time in the most glorious of
pursuits
is generally untrue right there is truth
to the old saying that idol hands are
the devil's workshop
but according to the left that's not
right right we have to capitalism
is bad because work is bad and therefore
what we really need to do is grab the
gains of capitalism and redistribute
them across society so we should be
cheering when people drop out of the
workforce we should be happy and if
you're feeling a little bit bad because
inflation is up and because you have to
pay a little bit more understand that
this is all in pursuit of a higher goal
this is all in pursuit of a higher end
and that higher end is a utopian system
in which
all of our basic needs are provided for
and we can sit around the campfire and
hang out with one another it is heaven
on earth
all it will require is for you to give
up your liberty to actually choose the
things you want right there's that
unspoken downside which is you no longer
get to prioritize your own needs
because after all those needs were a
false consciousness
and this does go back to marx the idea
that your prioritization of needs is
actually just a false consciousness that
has been put upon you by the economic
system change the economic system change
the nature of man create a happier man
through redistributive democratic
control of excess production and that's
the basic idea here paul krugman is
speaking that language
the left is speaking that language all
it's going to cost you is a worse
lifestyle in the here and now fewer
choices for your family and a complete
monopoly on how you live your life by
the people who know best who by the way
are so useless that they can go on
vacation for two months and nobody even
notices
alrighty before we wrap up the week you
know our friends over at birch gold
they're some of our best sponsors and we
really appreciate their advertising they
also have some interesting perspectives
on the nature of the economic situation
right now philip patrick a precious
metal specialist over there stopped by a
little bit earlier this week here's what
that sounded like
well as you all know our show is
sponsored by birch gold we are very
proud of that joining us on the line to
discuss the current financial situation
is philip patrick he's a precious metal
specialist you'll remember him from
prior shows and a lot has happened since
then phillip thanks so much for joining
the show really appreciate it
thanks for having me so let's talk about
the situation with the economy right now
the democrats are looking to blow an
enormous amount of money into the
economy they're debating over whether
they want to spend you know five
trillion or four trillion or three
trillion dollars they've not addressed
the debt ceiling
it's a precarious economic time for sure
and inflation is obviously headed the
wrong way what's going on
yeah um lots going on in in that respect
i mean right now with regards to the
debt ceiling it's pretty much deadlock
uh mcconnell uh insists the democrats
right now take the hardest possible path
to raising the debt ceiling or the debt
limit rather and to do it by themselves
senator schumer says no
last week they settled essentially on a
short-term hike to keep the government
limping along until december 3rd
and then we're going to go through the
whole thing again it appears
um there's a simple explanation for the
gridlock i think republicans are
refusing to sign a blank check
for ongoing
government and essentially democratic
spending they're demanding some form of
responsibility and the democrats aren't
interested in in collaborating on on a
responsible budget instead they're
demanding total control and it's it's
the essence of a standoff um to be clear
i don't expect the u.s to actually
default that would be
the financial equivalent of chernobyl
and i think
eventually the democrats will break down
and raise the debt ceiling via budget
reconciliation uh essentially without a
single republican vote which is what
mcconnell has been telling them to do
since july um the big issue i i think is
is one that you touched upon right
normally when the debt ceiling comes up
there's a negotiation there's a
balancing of fiscal responsibility and
agreed upon necessary spending but not
this time right this time we're talking
about raising the debt ceiling and at
the same time massive amounts of
spending which is insustainable and
ultimately fuels inflation uh the
inflation that we are seeing right now
is extraordinary the august cpi report
came in at 5.3 percent is it likely to
get better or likely to get worse
because we keep hearing from the fed
that it's temporary and then the
temporary turns into not so temporary
and so they're in sort of not so
temporary territory but uh how bad is
this gonna get
look it's already worse than the 5.3
that they're suggesting uh we're seeing
consumer price inflation today milton
friedman famously said inflation is
always and everywhere a monetary
phenomenon at any time that there's more
money without an equivalent rise in in
goods and services
prices go up it's basic economics um
the 5.3
number that the fed throw at us wolf
richter calls it the lowest of global
inflation measures
and even at this 5.3 that they're
suggesting that's a 30-year high most of
us weren't making our own financial
decisions 30 years ago we have no
comprehension of how this affects our
finances
remember this preferred measuring stick
that the fed use it's the lowest of
global because it gives essentially the
least frightening results if you measure
in the same the same inflation sorry in
the same way that the federal reserve
did back in the 90s
the way that john williams at shadow
stats does we look at nine percent
inflation today and that's just
factoring in things like food energy
health care costs things that used to be
factored in
because the fed keeping rates
artificially low while continuing to
pump money into the system
almost nothing today is offering a
positive after inflation yield not even
junk bonds
investors are so desperate for some kind
of safe haven for their money so they're
piling into risky and risky invest
investments and subsequently we're
seeing colossal asset bubbles
and some of them in you know strange
places obviously we're seeing in the
stock market
which is
double the historic average we have
proud house prices up 20 in the last
year um even treasury bonds are trading
at three times their historic average so
people are going crazy spending
millions of dollars on non-fundable
tokens on on on the blockchain pictures
of rocks and images of of gorillas
essentially as any escape valve from
from from the dollar and currency so
philip it doesn't look like it's going
to get better any time soon obviously
you've got the bind administration that
is essentially paying people to stay
home while telling the vast that they
shouldn't go to work because they should
be living in fear and the unvacs they
can't go to work because if they go to
work then they'll be violating vaccine
mandates and so you have massive supply
chain bottlenecks as well that makes it
really difficult to see the prices
decreasing on any of this stuff just
naturally anytime over the course of the
next few months
yeah i mean absolutely and quite frankly
inflation usually when it comes through
a market it's there to stay right the
only thing to to undo inflation or
deflationary periods and they tend to be
quite rare i think the last deflationary
period was second quarter of 2008 and it
lasted for months so usually when
inflation is is in the picture it's here
to stay and it certainly feels that way
today so we're speaking with philip
patrick of birch gold so obviously
philip you've talked about some of the
assets that people are putting money
into because it really is true i mean
you're looking at your money being worth
nothing if you leave it in the bank and
so you got to spend it on something and
then you've got the government on the
other end promising that they are going
to tax the living hell out of you so so
where should people be looking to put
their their cash at this point
look i think it's just about i mean
options are limited right and we joke
about it we are seeing bubbles in the
strangest of places right rare whiskey
indexes are all time highs luxury rocks
are all time highs people are looking
for an escape valve i think the key is
to understand the issues in the climate
and try and find an asset that's
conducive for that climate and and
something with the ability to weather
the storm and that's where i think
precious metals really come into play
right they're very conducive for the
problems that we have right corrections
in the markets inflation issues with
currency these problems a big issue for
anyone holding stocks and bonds in this
climate actually very conducive for safe
haven assets like gold and silver market
crashes drive them up inflation tends to
drive them up so very conducive like i
said for the issues and function as a
very effective hedge in this climate
that's philip patrick he's a precious
metal specialist over at birch gold if
you want to get involved with birch gold
ask them all your questions get your
answers text my name ben 47 47 47 today
and get involved with birch gold philip
thanks so much for the time appreciate
it thank you for having me
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com at 7 pm eastern 6
pm central tune in i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin